let's say i've got some subspace v which
tends to be our favorite letter for
subspaces and it's equal to the span
of two vectors in r4 let's say that the
first vector is one zero zero one
and the second vector
is
zero
one
zero
one
that is my subspace v and you can see
that these are going to be a basis that
these are linearly independent right two
vectors that are linear or any uh a set
of vectors that are linearly independent
and that span a subspace are a basis for
that subspace you can see they're
linearly independent this guy has a one
here there's no way that you can take
some combination of this guy to somehow
get a one there and then this guy has a
one here there's no way you can get some
linear combination of these zeros here
to get a one there so they're linearly
independent so you could also call this
you could also call this a basis
a basis
for
v
now given that let's see if we can find
out the transformation matrix for the
projection of any arbitrary vector onto
the subspace
so let's say that x we're dealing in r4
here right so let's say that x
let's say that x is a member
of r4 and i want to figure out what the
projection i want to figure out a
transformation matrix for the projection
projection onto v
of x
now in the last video we came up with a
general a general way to figure this out
we said if a is a transformation matrix
sorry if a is a matrix whose columns
whose columns are the basis for the
subspace so let's say a is equal to
1 0 0 1
0 1
0 1.
so a is a matrix whose columns are the
basis for a subspace then the projection
of x onto v would be equal to and this
is kind of hard
the first time you look at it gives you
a headache but there's a certain pattern
to or symmetry or a way of you could say
it's a
times you have something in the middle
and then you have a transpose
times your vector x
your vector x and the way i remember it
is in the middle you have these two guys
switched around so then you have a
transpose a
and you take the inverse of it
so you know i you you probably won't
you'd be using this in your everyday
life five or ten years from now so it's
okay if you don't memorize it but
temporarily put this in your medium term
memory because it's a good thing to know
you know for doing these projection
problems so if we want to find the
general linear the general matrix for
this transformation we just have to
determine what this matrix is equal to
and that's just a bunch of matrix
operations so that's a what is a
transpose
a transpose is going to be
a transpose
is going to be equal to
just all the rows turned to columns so
the first column becomes the first row
so it becomes one
zero zero one second column becomes the
second row zero one
zero one
that's what a transpose is now what's a
transpose a to figure out that
i want to figure out what a transpose
times a is
so let me multiply a transpose times a
so i'll rewrite a right here
one zero zero one
zero one
zero one this is give us some good
practice on matrix matrix products this
is going to be equal to what well first
of all we have this is a
two by four matrix and i'm multiplying
it by a 4 by 2 matrix so it's going to
be a 2
by 2 matrix
so the first entry is essentially the
dot product of
that row with that column so it's 1
times 1
plus
0 times 0
plus 0 times 0
plus 1 times 1 so it's just going to be
2 for that first entry right there and
then you take the dot product of this
guy with this guy right here so it's 1
times 0 which is 0
plus 0 times 1 which is 0 plus 0 times 0
which is 0 plus 1 times 1 which is 1.
now we do
this guy
this guy dotted with
this
column right there zero times one is
zero plus one times zero zero plus zero
times zero
is zero plus one times one is one
is one and then finally
this row
dotted with this second column second
row at second column zero times zero is
zero one times one is one zero times
zero is zero one times one is one so we
have one times one plus one times one so
it's going to be two
it's going to be equal to two so this
right here
that right there is a transpose a but
that's not good enough we need to figure
out what the inverse of a transpose a is
this is a transpose a but we need to
figure out a transpose a inverse
so what's the inverse of this
so let me write it here the inverse
a transpose a
inverse is going to be equal to what
it's 1 over the determinant of this guy
and what's the determinant here it's
going to be 1 over the determinant of
this the determinant is 2 times 2 which
is 4 minus 1 times one so it's four
minus
one which is three so one over the
determinant
times
this guy
times this guy where if i swap these two
so i swap the ones
sorry i swapped the twos
so
this two goes here and then this orange
two goes over here
and then i make these ones negative
so this becomes a minus 1 and this
becomes a minus 1. we learned that this
is a general solution for the inverse of
a 2x2 matrix i think it was
10 or 11 videos ago but and you probably
learned this in your algebra 2 class
frankly but there you go we have a
transpose a inverse so we have this guy
we have this whole guy here is just this
matrix i could multiply the 1 3 into it
but i don't have to do that just yet but
let's figure out the whole matrix now
the whole a times this guy a transpose a
inverse times a transpose
so let me write it this way
so the projection
the projection
onto the subspace v of x
is going to be equal to a
is going to be equal to a
one zero
zero one z let me do a little bit
let me write it a little bit bigger like
this so one zero zero one
zero one zero one
times a transpose a inverse right a
times a transpose a inverse
which is this guy right here and let's
just put the 1 3 out front just because
that's just a scalar so i'll put the one
third out front times this guy
this a transpose the inverse is 1 3
times
2 minus 1 minus 1
2
and then i'm going to multiply it times
a transpose
times a transpose and all of that times
our vector x so a transpose is right
there
a transpose is right there it is
1
0 0 1
0 1 0 1 and then all of that's going to
be times your vector x
so we still have some nice matrix matrix
products ahead of us let's see if we can
if we can
do these
so the first one let's just multiply
these two guys
let's multiply those two guys i don't
think there's any simple way to do it so
we have this is a 2 by 2 matrix and this
is a 2 by 4 matrix so when i multiply
them i'm going to end up with a i'm
going to end up with a 2 by a 2 by 4
matrix so let me write that 2 by 4
matrix right here
and then i can write this guy right here
one zero zero one
zero one zero one
and then i have the one third that was
from a transpose a inverse but i put the
scaling factor out there and all of this
is equal to the projection of x onto v
so let's do this product so this first
entry is going to be 2 times 1 plus
minus 1 times 0 so that is just 2. and
you're going to have 2 times 0 plus
minus 1
times 1. well that's minus 1. then you
have 2 times 0 plus minus 1 times 0.
well that's just 0.
and then you're going to have 2 times 1
2 times one plus minus one times one
that's two minus one that's just one
right two times one plus minus one times
one fair enough now let's do the second
row
minus one times one plus two times zero
so that's just minus one minus one times
zero plus two times one well that's just
two
minus one times zero plus two times zero
that's just zero
minus one times one
plus two times one well that's minus one
minus 1 plus 2 so that is
1.
almost there and of course we have to
multiply it times x at the end that's
what the that's what the transformation
is but this right here is our
transformation matrix
one more left to do let's hope i haven't
made any careless mistakes and that i
won't make any when i'm doing this
product because this is going to be a
little more complicated because this is
a 4 by 2 times a 2 by 4.
i'm going to end up with a 4 by 4 matrix
so let me give myself some breathing
room here because i'm going to be i'm
going to generate a 4x4
matrix right there
and so what am i going to get so this
first entry is going to be 1 times 2
plus 0
times -1 so it's just going to be equal
to 2. the next entry 1 times you know
this column
times sorry this row times any column
here is just going to be the first entry
in the column right because it gets
zeroed out so 1 times 2 plus 0 times
minus 1 is just 2.
1 times minus 1 plus 0 times 2 is just
minus 1 1 times 0 plus 0 times 0 is 0
1 times 1 plus 0 times 1 is just 1.
right when you take this row and you
multiply it times these columns you
literally just got your first row there
now let's do
this
let's do this row times these columns
now you've got a 0 here so you're going
to have a 0 times the first entry of all
of these and the 1 times the second one
so 0 times 2 plus 1 times minus 1 is
minus 1. 0 times minus 1 plus 1 times 2
is 2. you're just going to get the
second row here 2
0
1. and that actually makes sense because
if you just look at this part of the
matrix it's the 2 by 2 identity matrix
so anyway that's that's a little hint
why this looks very much like that but
we're just going to go through this
matrix product now you multiply this let
me do it in a different color you
multiply this guy times each of these
columns that guy dotted with that is
just going to be zero because this guy
is essentially the zero row vector so
you're just going to get a bunch of
zeros and then finally
this last
row it's one times the first entry plus
one times the second entry so this guy
is going to be two plus minus one which
is one
minus one plus two which is one zero
plus zero which is zero and then 1 plus
1 which is 2 and all of that times x and
there you have it
this is exciting
the projection the projection onto v of
x is equal to
this whole matrix times x so this thing
right here
this thing right here i could multiply
the 1 3 into it but we don't have to do
that that will just make it a little bit
more messy this thing right here is the
transformation matrix
the transformation matrix and it's a as
you can see since we're transforming
remember this projection
the projection onto v
this is a linear transformation from
r4
to r4
you give me some member of r4 and i'll
give you another member of r4 that's in
my subspace
that is the projection
so this is going to be a 4 by 4 matrix
you can see it right there anyway
hopefully you found that useful to
actually see a tangible result r4 is
very abstract so this would even be
beyond our three-dimensional programming
example this would be we're dealing with
a more abstract data set where we're
interested in finding a projection